je crois que la violence dans les stades
ici une véritable difficulté
pas plus en martinique qu'en métropole
mais ça reste un problème absolument
majeur et d'ailleurs les événements
récents au surnom était là pour le
démontrer c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons avec la ligue de football de
la martinique avec également la section
régionale de l'unaf ici en martinique
nous avons fait ce choix de renforcer
notre coopération pour être plus
efficace dans ce domaine et notamment
pour accélérer les procédures à la fois
les procédures disciplinaires et les
procédures pénales
c'est tout l'objectif de cette
convention de favoriser cette fluidité
qui veut nous permettra d'être encore
plus efficaces et cette efficacité doit
permettre à tout un chacun de bien
comprendre que ces violences sur les
arbitres sont rigoureusement les
strictement est strictement inadmissible
je rappelle que depuis 2006 larbitre à
ce statut de deux personnes chargées
d'une mission de service public ce n'est
pas rien ça veut dire beaucoup de choses
et ça veut dire que ce sont des
personnes qui doivent pouvoir bénéficier
d'une protection renforcée